[Music]
you grew up i don't know if you were
always comfortable with death but i knew
that you lived near a cemetery is that
right you live yeah or you live in
oh a pet cemetery cemetery yeah what's
it like living next to a pet cemetery
it's really fun it's really um
what are you doing right now
let's play fetch you throw a ball
nothing
yeah
i guess he fell in
all right he's dead yeah it was funny
actually because i moved to england when
i was a teenager and then um
my american friends would come and visit
me and they'd expect some kind of quaint
englishness and i was like guys
guess what i have and we'd go and there
was this pet cemetery that was next to
our house it was kind of this old house
and
people in england are really passionate
about their pets and they're passionate
everywhere you know but they had this
bonafide pet cemetery that looked
everything like a normal cemetery except
the names on it were like fluffy and
bobo and
they kind of sounded porn names like
like fluffer or even um
and so you had this like reading bobo's
not a porn name
in england in england
it's a porn name
bobo meets fluffy yeah and so the real
real monuments real like real monuments
that a human would have except it has
their silly uh it had like a portrait of
of bobo and fluff and and and you know
big ron i don't know
now you're trying to make them sound
like porn names
that was my cat ron jeremy yeah
that's all
what what uh that's not so weird yeah i
just love that you tell your teenage
friends have i got something for you la
la la pet cemetery
i think they think you're gonna bust out
a bong or something amazing is gonna
happen yeah no we had this funny little
gazebo though too and we used to
practice rolling splits with green tea
oh it didn't smoke on them smoking would
just make you weird it's kind of a
convoluted story but we used to let's
pursue this you would practice
smoking yeah uh marijuana but you would
use green tea we didn't want to waste it
because when you're a teenager you don't
have that much money and if you wanted
to smoke you're like all right i don't
know how to roll so and so my sister
kind of told me but i don't really
remember so i'm going to practice with
the tea leaf or a bunch of tea leaves
one will get you far um
and so we'd sit in this little gazebo
and like make these pretend stresses and
we thought we might as well just see
what happens when you smoke pg tips so
you get really caffeinated
look out kids
don't get caffeinated so that's what
happens yeah i'm like a tea pusher i
don't push drugs on people
but you get like an um earl grey man you
know
and then you shoot some milk okay
we're closing this down right now